martin biron sébastien bovet michel
sauget bonsoir un petit mot sur cette
rencontre virtuelle entre le président
américain et monsieur trudeau je disais
on attendait d'ici michel c'est le
soupir de soulagement de monsieur
trudeau quand il a dit bon dieu il a
presque dire comme ça d'ailleurs
j'exagère à peine le bon dieu que ça
fait du bien de revoir le leadership
américain ont fait en temps je crois
qu'on est l'extrait c'est en anglais et
on revient
on s'est vraiment nuit edith et du
leadership américaine chelsey gullickson
sondage 69% monsieur bah il donne deux
concerts alors qu'à monsieur pinault dit
les choses comme ça ils risquent pas
grand chose au canada et c'est un fait
que sans les etats-unis dans le dossier
des ressources climatique
c'est un problème au pouvoir de tout le
monde qui n'y croient que de ne pas
avoir les états unis à la table de ce
qu'ils soient retirés de la cour d'appel
alors là dessus je pense que toutes deux
laissé parler son coeur mais je pense
que probable puis blinken qui peut
parler français je sais pas s'il l'a
parler ou pas dans ce set petite
conversation enregistrée le se sont
secrétaires d'état qui parle français
la vice présidente qui a parlé de
montréal vraiment ces patients on
sentait vraiment beaucoup de d'atomes
crochus s'arrête l'heure pas tout mais
disons que c'est un point de départ
c'est ce que j'avais dit sur la forme il
ya des atomes crochus le coureur doit
passer le temps on va changer c'est
évident maintenant sur le fond il va
rester des points litigieux le
protectionnisme de monsieur bart hayden
qui se tourne excellent les pipelines et
autres donc oui il ya comme un renouveau
un vendre nouveau mais ça veut pas dire
que sur le fond des choses il va pas y
avoir des accrochages entre le canada et
les états unis
monsieur trudeau espère probablement
avoir des espèces de d'allègement du buy
american act pour faire en sorte que les
économies canadienne et américaine qui
sont enchâssés l'une avec l'autre puisse
fonctionner de bain et on à martin au
québec au gouvernement du québec de
grandes ambitions pour la filière
électrique notamment toutes ces
entreprises du québec qui va à l'essai
mais puis elle y vend des produits
c'est important c'est une opportunité
la mcc ce que monsieur legault a
toujours souhaité en fait faire du
québec ou de lait l'hydroélectricité en
fait de faire du québec la batterie
électrique du nord et oui ça va
faciliter les relations
c'est sûr comme sébastien disait il va y
avoir des écueils mais au moins on parle
le même langage le même langage
diplomatique et on sentait que monsieur
trudeau et à moins sur ses gardes
alors ça va être la même chose au
gouvernement du québec quand on va
commencer à faire des affaires il va y
avoir plus de fluidité dans les
relations même s'il ya des désaccords
nécessairement intéressant que j'ai
oublié nous utiliser le mot langage
comme si le code on était revenu au même
code à la même langue diplomatique et
politique
donc oui des désaccords mais le lexique
et le même parce que monsieur jobs avait
fait voler lexique politique et tout le
reste
alors ok à suivre vaccination
vaccination les 85 ans et plus on écoute
monsieur locaux
vacciner c'est gagner donc vacciner les
québécois s'est cognée contre la
pandémie
on est déjà passé dans tous les chu
celle d'e.on a déjà peu près la moitié
des rpa dans les résidences pour les
personnes âgées qui sont faites on a
presque 200 mille employés du réseau de
la santé où c'est fait donc l'or ça va
s'accélérer dans les autres groupes de
la société
mais l'espoir est là bon alors martin
évidemment on se croise les doigts au
gouvernement du québec on souhaite que
ça se déroule bien mais là c'est lent
c'est la pauvre elle a ouais ça va être
un gros mois le mois de mars
parce que quand même il reste encore
neuf cent mille doses si on veut
atteindre l'objectif de 1 million 300
mille personnes doses de vaccin injecté
si la fin du mois de mars
on a senti monsieur legault quand même
assez de bonne humeur aujourd'hui là
c'est quand même des bonnes nouvelles
mais on a senti une certaine prudence ou
si on serre les dents c'est pas pour
rien qu'on vaccine seulement les gens de
85 ans et plus on veut redonner le
système s'assurer que ça fonctionne bien
on a répété souvent utilisé l'internet
parce qu'on veut pas engorger on regarde
ce qui se passe en ontario on regarde ce
qui se passe avec les voyageurs tawahi y
est on sait que les électeurs en fait
que les québécois vont juger
gouvernement sur cette opération de
vaccination qui demande beaucoup de
doigté de logistique oui parce que
michel scipion donne un numéro d'air et
je rappelle à ses je dis que ça comment
les gens écrit je vois que sarah j'ai
essayé ça marche pas c'est pas tout de
suite c'est jeudi j'ai le raid 5 février
et oncle 1 1 8 7 7 6 4 4 45 45
rappelez-vous du 1 8 ans à l'époque et
michel au début de la crise ou alors ça
va il ya eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
la logistique qui là dedans est la
source de tous les problèmes d'habitude
là
l'informatique marché dans cette
affaire-là ci est alors ils ont aimé les
raisons de craindre ça parce que c'est
vraiment des fois un petit détail qui
fait que ça ne fonctionne pas ce qui va
être difficile aussi que mettons là des
gens 85 ans sont pas toujours
nécessairement très alerte sur internet
allait trouver le site remplir les
formulaires nécessaires pour remplir le
numéro d'assurance maladie dû chasser
les choses qui sont plus compliquées et
ça peut susciter des erreurs puis chacun
leur succès d'un problème informatique
qui parle
alors ça c'est de cesser ses dents c'est
le grand danger lorsqu'elle n'existe pas
c'est pareil nous disait tout à l'heure
je demandais mais l'accompagnateur
pourra parce que un accompagnateur peut
aller chercher la personne qui habite
seule à la maison par exemple qu à 81,7
ans ici l'accompagnateur en 70 ans et
plus il pourra se faire vacciner en même
temps donc on a aménagé quand même pour
faciliter la vie autant que possible des
gens âgés oui il ya eu un peu de
confusion dans le point presse parce que
en effet le site du gouvernement dit que
comme vous dites si bien quelqu'un qui a
plus de 70 ans qui accompagne quelqu'un
qui aurait plus que 85 va pouvoir se
faire vacciner à de condition d'avoir
plus de 70 ans est la première condition
à donner des soins ou est trop près de
sept personnes de plus de 85 ans trois
fois par semaine qui s'annonce il est
par exemple un coupé dans le
un des membres à 86 ans puis l'autre 91
79 ans on voit pas pourquoi ils seraient
pas vaccinés les deux rassemblements
antérieurs c'est logique vous voulez pas
qu'ils prennent deux rendez-vous
maintenant se déplacer deux fois la
difficulté à se déplacer le judo
souplesse un peu oui c'est une bonne
question
un couple quand différence d'âge qu'ils
y vont ensemble allons-y on va faire on
va prendre les deux parce que martin
puis monsieur le ministre a répondu à ça
au lieu dit la la pression est sur
québec la laci plus ottawa c'est vous ça
vous de jouer là on se rappelle de la
voiture de sa métaphore sur la voiture
neuve là on a une voiture solide forte
mais on n'a pas d'essence mais là
l'essence commence à arriver alors faut
que la voiture fasse un peu de millage
alors oui le gouvernement est sur les
dents sur cette question love c'est
normal parce que et on veut bien partir
et c'est monsieur legault le répéter le
vacciner c'est gagner alors on commence
à sortir de la crise on veut pas
s'embourber
c'est certain qu'ils vont vouloir que ça
fonctionne bien et on sent qu'on a pris
des mesures pour le jeu juste à ce sujet
la patrie ce maxi nation va s'accélérer
à partir du 1er avril
6 2 2 entre avril et septembre c'est là
que le gros de la vaccination reste
faire et on va recevoir à peu près 10
millions et demi de doses là pour
vacciner autour de 5 et 6 millions de
québécois c'est 70 à 80% de la
population
c'est pas de l'essence ordinaire que ça
va prendre dans le moteur du
gouvernement c'est du super parce que à
ce rythme là entre avril et septembre va
falloir vacciner entre 350 et 400 mille
personnes par semaine alors que la
capacité théorique dont on parle c'est
250 milles par semaine peut-être qu'on
est capable de pousser un peu plus mais
ça vous donne une idée de l'ampleur du
défi de 6 septembre
si on veut que tous les québécois qui
veulent être vaccinés soit maxime bon un
petit aux 1 2 et d'ailleurs merci michel
ça me donne l'occasion de rappeler que
les gens qui appellent ou qui écrivent à
québec coincé à barres obliques vaccin
covin euros le rendez vous pour la
deuxième dose automatiquement donc
j'appelais à partir de jeudi
on va nous dire venez mercredi prochain
à telle adresse vous choisissez pas vous
dîtes moi je vais aller au stade
ils vont vous
vous allez selon votre code postal on
vous envoie l'endroit le plus proche qui
on va vous donner un autre rendez vous
pour la deuxième dose qui incidemment la
deuxième dose doit commencer à se donner
parce qu'on a dit 90 jours donc on a
encore 30 jours
c'est bassidj combler oui les premières
personnes ont été vaccinées à la
mi-décembre à peu près donc ça donne
jusqu'à la mi mars si je calcul bien
donc c'est ça on est et on dit que la
deuxième dose sera donné dans les 90
jours n'a pas l'intention d'étendre sa
plus longue
ok les seules deux classes on en a parlé
hier des avis de la santé publique mais
il ya un avis qui disait où vous devriez
donner des cours devant des deux me sall
ou aux primaires même plutôt que des
salles complètes et monsieur legault a
dit écoutez leur c'était pas possible et
vous allez entendre sa route à dire on
accepter la réponse de monsieur legault
disant que ce n'est pas possible on est
content que j'ai compris surtout des
gens du ministère d'éducation
c'est que c'était pas idéal pour les
enfants d'en avoir la moitié en classe
pour la moitié à maison parcours à
distance exactement un fait puis
comprendrez qu'on est pas des experts en
pédagogie et puis il ya des questions
toujours de faisabilité nouveau des
chances et des adaptations de nos
recommandations
bon tour de tam tour de table rapide
là-dessus martin
ben c'est pas simple de régler ça quand
est autour de la table qui veut garder
des écoles ouvertes
il y en a une qui milite pour certaines
façons de le faire donc pas les écoles
secondaires ou privées ont fait ça et ça
très bien fonctionné mais aux primaires
la garder l'attention de d'élèves en
ligne en même temps que tant à
l'intérieur d'une classe à marc denis il
faut que tu te calcule tentons riscle et
la capacité d'agir en fait dans ce cas
là c'est pas plus strict que la santé
publique c'est le seul cas où il a été
moins strict parce qu'on a continué à
avoir des classes pleines puis voilà
c'est ce qui a fait jaser puis là où
l'opposition étaient très durs envers le
ministre l'éducation entre autres la
dessus me chasser oui c'est un peu ce
qu'est ce qu'elle impose si on fait d'un
impact elle parle ainsi de chercher le
maillon faible
sappi dessus sur la berge mais c'est
ainsi les marchés d'asie c'est pas nous
c'est assez exacte mais la santé
publique n'est pas une science exacte on
fait ce qu'on peut
et dans ce cas là si c'était pas
possible et effectivement tout prix
mettre beaucoup de bursa premier mais ça
doit se faire ça et s il à masquer au
premier se décider sur pas monsieur reid
a de vraies histoires et ces déchets si
j'en reparle c'est canal qui ont
l'impression puis je vois parfois passer
des analyses
parce que la santé publique a dit ceci
c'est une vérité de la palice c'est que
ça c'est la vie est parfaite comme ça
malheureusement c'est plus compliqué
qu'est ce qui se passe avec votre votre
reine votre à mouiller à québec martin
bucer ciel ne savons pas du tout mais
martin le sait c'est un dossier qui
polarise beaucoup la population il ya ya
ya ya même des groupes
leurs ailes tramway non merci alors ça
polarise beaucoup quand on décortique
les sondages on se rend compte que le
centre est plus favorable les banlieues
et moi sont moins favorables et monsieur
legault à ces circonscriptions dans les
banlieues est clairement ça divise aussi
son propre conseil des ministres alors
monsieur legault décision et décidé
finalement d'acheter du temps de se
placer entre les deux en penchant un peu
plus pour les banlieues mais ce que je
comprend des conversations que j'ai eu
le dessus c'est que le gouvernement va
attendre huit mois c'est à dire
l'élection municipale qui s'en vient est
ce que monsieur la bombe va se présenter
ou non s'il se présente ça risque de
devenir un genre de l'élection
référendaire sur le tramway et qu'après
ça la décision du gouvernement va se
prendre sur la question du tramway dont
sébastien ouais parce que c'est votre
mère était pas content hier et on est
traité comme un village ya des
dépassements de coûts mais regardez à
montréal est claire m pour va parler
dans une seconde avec michel c moi je
suis traité pas de façon équitable
oui parce qu'on dépense beaucoup sur les
aime le rem avance le même le troisième
dans la région de québec a l'air
d'avancer plus vite que le tramway qui
est un peu au point mort mais ça va au
delà de ça c'est à dire que monsieur
labeaume laisse entendre qu'il avait une
entente avec françois bonnardel le
ministre des transports monsieur
bonnardel ou d'aujourd'hui dit qui avait
pas d'entente donc il ya quelqu'un
quelque part qui a pas compris ce qui se
passait au cap a compris la même chose
ou qui manquent donc il ya une escalade
dans le ton dans les mots utilisés et le
constat le résultat c'est que ça sert
pas les gens de québec qui veulent en
majorité à 56% un tramway au projet de
transport structure celle ci leur m
autre sujet mais un de vos sujets
préférés
le jury se déplacer ça pas pour pas
porteur pour jeter que des fleurs à
laquelle la leur m2 laisse pour que les
gens se situe c'est le prolongement donc
de l'ess vers le centre ville
phase 2 sur le boulevard rené lévesque y
aurait une structure surélevée
il ya des gens il ya une partie des gens
dont les architectes qui ont claqué la
porte qui était au projet qu'ils disent
a pas de bon sens de faire une structure
surélevée au centre-ville
c'est un crime la quinzaine
savez-vous on n'a pas d'argent pour
faire autre chose ça va être ça j'en ai
tous là devant tout ça d'abord la caisse
dit toujours ça doit être ça avec la
caisse tout est à prendre ou à laisser
ils ont décidé de la technologie sur des
types de wagons les uns décidé et c'est
ça si vous voulez pas c'est tout ça
c'est un peu fatigué parce qu'à un
moment donné
le gouvernement doit aussi avoir son mot
à dire là bas c'est lui qui va payer à
la fin ça c'est le premier problème le
deuxième c'est que tu es passé vous
vraiment que sur une grue les plus
prestigieuses en france et au niveau du
4e étage des traits aux deux à cinq
mètres
la façade de l'édifice comment vous
allez vendre un condo ou louer un bureau
dans ces circonstances là c'est une
perte de valeur est celle est très
silencieux en français c'était
électrique ceci à ce fait de jeu du jeu
même si vous avez vos doutes on va faire
on va leur prendre je suis est loin
d'être terminée ont soufflé à dire un
mot sur ce débat qui fait rage entre
autres dans la région de montréal sur le
prolongement du rêve
merci à vous trois alors vous avez
constaté que monsieur bail de monsieur
truc devons attendre un peu avant de
vous parler nous parler aux canadiens ou
américains donc ce sera dans l'émission
de gerald mais on fait une petite pause
sans attendre